en esta ocasión nos preguntan cuántos
palillos vamos a necesitar para formar
la figura 50 de esta secuencia así que
vamos a echar un vistazo a esta
secuencia en el primer caso en la
primera figura de esta secuencia que por
cierto parece como una pequeña casa
cuantos palillos tenemos aquí pues
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 palillos así que
nuestra primera figura que tenemos aquí
o el primer objeto va a tener 6 palillos
en ella 6 palillos ahora cuántos
palillos necesitamos en nuestra segunda
figura bueno nosotros tenemos estos 6
palillos de la primera figura esta es la
primera figura que tenemos aquí déjenme
remarcar la para que quede todo claro
esta es la primera figura que tenemos a
la izquierda este de aquí y vamos a
aumentar esta otra parte cuántos
palillos nuevos vamos a tener que
aumentar pues son 1 2 3 4 y 5 así que
ahora tenemos 6 palillos más otros cinco
nuevos palillos
suma 6 palillos la figura original más
cinco nuevos palillos que estamos
aumentando y esto es igual a 11 palillos
ahora qué pasa en este tercer objeto en
esta tercera figura de casas pegadas una
a la otra pues bien de estas primeras
dos casas ya sabemos que tenemos 11
palillos no es así es la misma figura
que la figura 2 y cuantos más vamos a
agregar pues vamos a agregar la misma
figura que agregamos en el objeto 2
justo esta que está aquí a la izquierda
y vamos a agregar la misma extensión a
nuestra casa si lo quieres visualizar de
esa manera así que nuevos palillos vamos
a tener 1 2 3 4 y este 5 esto lo podemos
decir que cada vez que vamos abajo en
esta secuencia o mejor visto de esta
manera cada vez que agregamos un nuevo
término a nuestra secuencia o un nuevo
objeto a nuestra secuencia vamos a
aumentar 5 palillos así que tenemos 11 5
11 palillos esta parte de aquí más cinco
nuevos palillos lo cual es 16 lo mismo
para esta nueva
tenemos la misma figura anterior es
decir 16 palillos de esta parte del
dibujo y vamos a dibujarlo con mucho
cuidado vamos a remarcar lo para que tú
me creas que esto es lo que ya teníamos
anteriormente lo remarcamos con buen
pulso y después le vamos a agregar cinco
nuevos palillos para así obtener la
nueva figura por lo tanto tenemos 16 más
5 lo cual es 21
entonces con esta información como
podemos encontrar cuantos palillos vamos
a tener en la figura 50 y bueno
podríamos dibujar aquí las 50 figuras y
después contar todos los palillos pero
eso suena a que nos va a llevar una
eternidad así que mejor vamos a fijarnos
en el patrón que estamos encontrando a
cada paso agregamos 5 palillos o tal vez
podemos encontrar la fórmula para la
nueva figura cuántos palillos tendría la
nueva figura así que vámonos por partes
aquí en la primera figura lo puedes ver
de la siguiente manera tenemos un
palillo más cinco palillos estás de
acuerdo
este primer palillo el cual puedes
pensar que siempre estuvo ahí y después
agregamos otros 5 palillos más así que
este es el primer término de nuestra
secuencia en el segundo término de
nuestra secuencia que es lo que tenemos
bueno pues el segundo término es el
término anterior lo cual es 6 100 por
ciento lo podemos ver como 15 como 15
más el patrón que son otros 5 palillos
es decir más 5 muy bien y en nuestro
tercer término de nuestra secuencia pues
tenemos todos estos palillos que tenemos
en nuestra segunda figura es decir 15 +
5 ya esto le vamos a agregar otros 5
palillos más es decir más 5 y por último
en nuestro cuarto término que vamos a
tener pues vamos a tener los mismos
palillos en el tercero lo cual es 15 55
ya esto a todos estos le vamos a agregar
otros 5 + + 5 lo que estamos obteniendo
4 veces 5
qué hacemos con toda esta información
porque bueno date cuenta que si
escribimos la primera figura como 15 es
para que veas lo siguiente mira tengo
uno más
una vez 5 en la segunda figura mira
tengo 12 veces 5 en la tercera mira
tengo 13 veces 5 y en la cuarta que
crees mira tengo uno más cuatro veces 5
así que ya puedes ver el patrón si tengo
el término n entonces voy a tener uno
más en bs 5 estás de acuerdo en el
primer término es más un 5 en el segundo
término es más 25 en el tercer término
es más 35 en el cuarto término son más
45 así que en el término n por ejemplo
tiene fuera 10 tendríamos 1 más 10 5 en
el término n vamos a tener uno más en 5
si lo vemos de una manera un poquito
abstracta así que si tenemos el término
50 que es justo es lo que nos pregunta
el problema qué es lo que pasa en la
figura 50 en él
unos 50 cuantos palillos vamos a tener
pues vamos a tener 150 ps 5 verdad 150 x
5 y en este caso n es igual a 50 lo cual
es igual a am 50 por 5 es 250 exacto más
uno tenemos 251 251 palillos en la
figura 50 de esta secuencia vamos a
necesitar 251 palillos para armarla